Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
the book of fasting,
the chapter regarding the pillars
of fasting.
The pillars of fasting.
We mentioned yesterday morning
that fasting has how many pillars?
Two. Two pillars.
The first one
is
intention.
And the second one
emptiness. Yes. Refraining from anything
that breaks one's fast.
Intention
is the condition
of all conditions.
It is a condition in every act of
worship.
There are few acts of worship that are
valid without intention.
And so this is kind of a standard,
right? And we mentioned that intention
is in the heart. It places in the heart
but intention for fasting
if it is an obligatory fasting
the month of Ramadan fasting fasting a
vow any kind of fasting that is
obligatory
then
what is the
then a person must have his intention
before
the break of dawn
correct before the break of dawn. And a
good point to mention here and we'll
mention it again later inshallah and
that is that
when it comes to alabat
making up
fasting that a person has missed of
Ramadan.
Any day that a person makes up outside
of Ramadan,
once they engage in that fast, it has
the exact same rulings as Ramadan,
right?
So for instance, a person may break his
may have an allowance during Ramadan
to break his fast, illness, travel,
whatever. a woman breaks her fast or
is not fasting because of her cycle,
she is then able to make it up any day
throughout the coming year.
It's a difference of opinion on whether
or not she must make it up immediately
when she is able or he or any time
throughout the year. an issue we will
discuss in due time inshallah.
However,
most of the scholars view that a person
is able to choose any day that they wish
from the coming year to make up that day
of fasting that they missed in Ramadan.
But once they begin the fasting, so
notice, you can choose any day you want,
but once you begin the day of fasting,
you're now locked into it just you
would be in the day of Ramadan, right?
It now becomes just as obligatory as the
day of Ramadan is. And it it then has
the same rulings as if it were the month
of Ramadan. So intention has to be made
before the break of dawn for obligatory
fasting.
[Silence]
When
He mentions a general
evidence and this is another thing we
will take real quick and that is that
how do we organize evidence
right because not all evidence is on the
same level.
It's not on the same level of strength.
It's not on the same level of clarity.
It's not on the same level of
it's not on the same it's not all the
same. We can have general evidences,
specific evidences. We can have
evidences that mention something by name
that mention something by its
description, right?
evidence from the Quran, evidence from
the Sunnah, evidence from different
places in the Sunnah, whether it's
from the prophet's words or from his
actions or from his companions or from
his So evidences are not all the same.
They're on different levels.
So when we go to look at the way that
the scholars have structured their
arguments,
we start with the way that Allah has
structured the arguments that he
mentions in the Quran. And how are those
arguments mentioned?
Every major chapter of the Quran usually
structures these arguments in the same
way.
And that is that the introduction to the
chapter, the beginning and opening
verses of the chapter will mention the
general
arguments
and then he will become it will become
more and more specific
as the chapter continues
and then at the end of the chapter it
draws conclusions and ties back to the
beginning and ties all the evidences
together. So you begin at kind of a
bird's eyee view and you home in right
the same thing
the scholars do in their arguments
when they wish to mention an evidence
for something they begin first with a
general evidence
a general rule if you will then they
will become more and more specific in
their evidences being that this book
here is
by by definition it's a very summarized
book. It's meant to be memorized by
students of hadith. It's meant to be
a kind of handbook if you will for
the general Muslim.
So by definition it's going to be very
very summarized and very abridged in
that. So, it's not going to mention
every single evidence,
but we still see the same structure and
that is that he begins with a general
evidence from the Quran, a general
evidence for the Sunnah, and then a
specific evidence from the Quran. If
it's there, then a specific evidence
from the Sunnah. This is how he has
structured the book. This is how most
arguments are structured. So he begins
with a general evidence
from the Quran
meaning not specific to Ramadan but in
general
that intention is a condition in all
acts of worship. So he begins with the
fifth verse of surah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says regarding
the previous nations meaning all nations
were commanded with the same thing that
this nation is commanded with and that
is
[Silence]
He says, "And the previous nations,
namely the Jews and Christians, were
ordered not except that they were to
worship Allah, making sincere to him all
acts of worship. ship.
so the point here is making sincere to
him all acts of worship. That is
intention. Intentionality
that not only do I intend to worship but
I intend to worship Allah alone without
any partners. So that's an evidence for
intention. Intentionality being
a condition in all acts of worship.
Then he mentions the general
evidence from the Sunnah, an narration
that has been collected by all of the
major books of hadith. It's the
narration of Omar.
It's usually one of the first narrations
anyone learns
in which the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said
deeds are but by intention. Meaning
deeds are
rewarded and judged and weighed based
on the intention
of the person who does the deed
and indeed for each person what he has
intended. This narration as we mentioned
is in all the six books the major six
books of hadith including Musad Ahmed
and others. Then he mentions a specific
narration a specific evidence from the
Sunnah
regarding
having intention to fast the day of
Ramadan
before the break of dawn of the intended
day.
He says,
[Silence]
He says, "And a person must have his
intention
to fast
before the break of dawn before fud then
of each night. So the night comes before
the day. So before the break of dawn any
time during that night the person must
have the intention to fast the following
day and this is due to the narration of
the prophet's wife's
daughter
in which she narrates that the messenger
of Allah
said,
"Whoever has not
intended
to fast before the break of dawn, then
their fasting is not valid."
Okay? Whoever has not
solidified
his intention to fast before the break
of dawn,
then his fasting is not valid.
Now, if you'll notice, the way that
we have worded this is that an
obligatory fast. So we say Ramadan
kafow
right another etc. This is all types of
obligatory fast
fast for
fasting because of unintentional
killing of a Muslim etc accidental.
These are types of obligatory fasting
and the intention must be arrived at and
solidified before the break of dawn.
So what about an optional
fast? If a person is going to fast every
Monday and Thursday or three days out of
the month or if a person wishes to fast
the six days of Sha or a person wishes
to fast every other day or a person
wishes to fast
or the the 10 the 10th of or
the day of etc. optional fasting.
Does it have the same rule? Generally,
yes. Specifically, no. And this has its
own chapter which we'll delve into
inshallah when we arrive at that. But
for our intents and purposes, obligatory
fast, a person must have solidified
his intention. He must have arrived at a
coherent
intention to fast the following day
before the break of dawn.
Before the break of dawn for the day
that he wishes to fast. This narration
of hapsa has been collected by Abu Di
and so three of the four books of sun.
the second pillar of fasting.
And so before we move on,
there may be a lot of questions in your
minds right now. for instance, what
about if a person doesn't know that it's
Ramadan yet until midway through the
day? What if a person only finds out
after fud? But if these kinds of
incidental things we will
discuss them at the end of this book at
the end of this book meaning the book of
fasting. It has its own chapters which
we'll deal with there. First we want to
have a solid foundation and then we
start to go into the exceptions to the
rule. First we learn the rules. Then we
learn the exceptions and how to deal
with them. Right?
So the second pillar of fasting is
refraining
from anything that will break a person's
fast from the break of dawn until the
sun sets.
Refraining from anything that will break
a person's fast
from the break of dawn until the sun
sets.
And the evidence for this
for
[Silence]
insanity.
and
[Silence]
what the whole
He says, "And the evidence for this
second pillar
is
the statement of Allah." Verse
187 of Bakar in which Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says that which translates to and
eat all of you and drink until the white
thread is distinguished from the black
thread on the horizon at the break of
dawn.
and then continue to hold your fast
until nightfall.
Okay,
so we will discuss this verse in more
[Arabic recitation]
But
what is important here for our intents
and purposes is to take
the aspect of the verse that the author
intended
for this
issue and that is that Allah commands us
to eat and drink until the break of
dawn. Until up until the break of dawn.
Then you cease eating and drinking until
nightfall. And nightfall begins
in the Arabic language and in Islamic
legislation at the sunset.
The thing that is going through a lot of
our minds when we hear this kind of
topic discussed in this way is
sheh we already know this
right?
Of course we know this. I know this ever
since I was a little little boy that I'm
supposed to hold my fast from the break
of dawn until the sun sets and that I'm
supposed to refrain from eating and
drinking anything, etc.
Are we What are we doing here? Why are
we over complicating something?
Are we chewing water here in this
gathering? We already know this.
The answer is
this is the difference
between knowledge
and ignorance.
Knowledge
and blind following.
It's not that you know the conclusion,
it's that you know where the conclusion
comes from.
It's not just that you know the answer,
but that you know the evidence for that
answer. That's what scholarship is.
That's what knowledge is. Knowledge is
having evidence.
And this is something that has honestly
become overlooked.
For instance,
if I were to say to you right now,
what is one kind of filth
that if it's on your clothing or your
person or your place of salah,
if you were to pray, it would invalidate
your prayer.
Number one thing that comes to mind,
huh?
Yes.
So we say filth, right? Well, how many
types of filth are there?
So for instance, stool or or
you know
defecation
is that filthy human defecation. Is it
filthy? It's filthy, right? What's the
evidence for that?
No, I need a I need an evidence
that that's filthy. Specifically that
[Silence]
I need an evidence that human feces is
filthy. That's the evidence I need.
I don't want a general thing. I need an
evidence for that. We all know that,
right? Is there anyone here who does not
know that? Every one of us knows that.
What's the evidence for it? Because just
saying I know that or everyone knows
that or that's common knowledge. That's
not an evidence.
That's not evidence.
Christians all know common knowledge
that Jesus was crucified. They all know
that he's one of three. They all know
that he's the son of God. So tell me
what is the evidence that human feal
matter is filthy and that it will
invalidate your prayer.
See this is the difference between
scholarship and ignorance or between
knowledge and following.
When we do what's called which you must
do, you can't know every single thing
always, right? It's not possible. Even
major scholars will have certain issues
that they do on because life is short
and they're not able to research every
single tiny thing. Right? That's why
there's so many scholars. They all
complete each other. Whatever this one
misses, the other one has. They form a
whole collectively.
But the issue here is the difference
between knowledge and
because aid
by definition is not a person of
knowledge.
Right? Saying for instance, how many
prayers are there in a day? Five
prayers.
What's the evidence for that? Evidence.
We all know that. We're not calling this
into question. But this is what
knowledge is. So maybe tomorrow somebody
can tell me what that evidence is.
Right? Under one condition, don't use
Google.
Find it. Find it. Okay.
What is that?